we have John Leguizamo here is he here
he's coming in he's on his way John
Leguizamo is promoting Latin history for
morons it's on tour he's bringing his
show that he was doing in New York all
over the place to Durham North Carolina
to Miami to Michigan to Philly to Dallas
San Antonio Los Angeles Washington DC
you can do any of those cities you're
going to be able to see John Leguizamo
and if you're a [ __ ] this is the show
for you
is that right John get unmooring eyes
you could get on [ __ ] I'm fine I'm dumb
offical yeah one-man shows have you done
too many sixth is my sixth isn't it
award or something I get free coffee or
something like that so you got a punch
card yeah isn't it nice to know that you
have that ability though that you can
write and produce and perform a one-man
show so if anything ever were to dry up
for you you're like I just I just write
my own [ __ ] and go on saying it's true
it's do I have my fallback career you
know like if the movies aren't kicking
in or the TV shows yeah I can go to a
club I can even go to a club and do some
some some bitter so you still do
stand-up at all or no no I'm not a
stand-up oh you didn't start it no no I
never started a stand-up I was I did
improv and then I started writing
one-man shows from the get-go like 20
minute pieces and performance art spaces
yeah like if your characters were when
you really started a breakout right
right right I was I was a storyteller
you know and I did characters and I
would just happen to be physical and
funny at the same time what was the
first character you're like all right I
can do 20 minutes of this it was it was
a it was a biblical piece at gusto house
in Alphabet City and it was his and it
was like as the Bible were all Latin
people so you know Jesus had a Latin
accent and Mary and everybody so I've
played all the characters if it's bombed
Richard Pryor said that when he's doing
some like mud bones or whatever if it
was bombing it was easier to deal with
because it wasn't him bombing it was the
character bombing do you do if something
is tanking do you look at how you don't
feel like you're Bobby I'm not gonna
hide behind I mean that's my face is
right that's you
and this is boring I'm sorry people and
then I have to try to get out of it
somehow come up with a better what do
you say that's hard you get joke or
something yeah yeah it's always the
character could you dick jokes do ya
have you had a character that you like
or this is gonna be great and you try it
two or three nights you know like it
just stinks it never catches on that's
happened to me lots of times lots of
times I had like up I guess when I
started out I had a Rastafarian sort of
a love connection guy that didn't work
the accent sucked the character suck the
dialogue suck that I killed it it just
went nowhere
no way yeah I was like talking about
number two I tell you things about about
your girlfriend now I tell you now it
was like shut up looking at you yeah you
can't be other stuff really well because
then when you try something new and it's
only okay it's like nah that's not it
yeah yeah
I don't enjoy myself that way either you
don't I like to rock it or just get out
so when you go to write it's either a
win or a loss yeah yeah yeah I wish I
was one of those guys that could just
enjoy the coasting and stuff yeah you
try if you're doing a show this is a new
character and a try and you know to give
it five minutes do you have those system
where you work in something new that's
really short so vivid [ __ ] stinks it
doesn't rectify work it out at home in
front of myself for like a long time and
then when I think it makes me laugh then
then it usually works it usually works
that's amazing though cuz most people
can't hey George you can't yeah you
can't judge what an audience is gonna do
it I don't I I don't I don't write for
an audience I write for myself
mm-hmm and if I that's that's always
been my barometer it's like I'm writing
for me and if I make me laugh
that that's cool and if people don't
laugh sometimes I'm okay cuz I think
it's you enjoy it yeah yeah I can't like
how prints approached music yeah yeah
I'm like the the Latin sort of Prince no
no I wish I was that good but the worst
is when you find something you think
they're gonna like it and you're like
this is I really like they just hate it
when I first did Latin history for
morons at the clubs in Buffalo New York
perfect spot right the poor people they
were didn't know what they were in for
because it was three hours long I read
out of my
computer and it was a lot of history and
I was in love with this history yeah I
mean I was talking about Vietnam Latin
people's contribution to Vietnam world
war one world war two war of 1812 nobody
wants to talk about the war of 1812 oh
man they hated me well did you go up
there saying this is what I'm do I'm
working this out so just kind of watch
you work it out yeah theater but you
know people they spend a lot of money
and yeah they want to see the past up
there they want to see to one food
you're gonna be educated yeah I'm gonna
take you through with Latin history for
the last 3,000 years
year by year so do you enjoy that part
though because you now I loved it so you
have to become responsible though for
the information whereas when you're
doing these like characters that are
really comedy based culturally you're
responsible for representing that
culture properly beyond that you can
pick up on stuff that you grew up with
on the block or whatever it was but I
mean when you're talking about stuff
that you're doing just or I mean there's
no there's no fact-checking
yeah yeah you just you just got to tell
a great story no but yeah I mean I had
to come up with a system how am I gonna
I had to come up with a way of smuggling
information that's what it was it was
like how can I get as much history
without turning them off so that was the
balance that I spent years and years
perfecting is like okay they need
something personal analogous to the
history and make the history as funny as
[ __ ] yeah yeah that without so that I
could get information because I wanted
to get information I didn't want to just
make them laugh I'm not gonna be happy
if that's all I had when you started
learning this history for this show and
really started all staring like [ __ ]
right and you see all this Latin here oh
my god just part of you go like what the
[ __ ] why was it wide it is nobody's been
taught this Jose like Latin history's a
mystery dude I was so angry I was so
angry for that to happen no but I was
really angry yeah I was really angry and
then I was really sad and and and then
frustrated and outraged yeah and it's
kind of like what the audiences are
feeling so do you feel that like Latin
people have been given too much credit
in American history
we were totally excluded I mean when I
found out that with the second oldest
ethnic group in America mm-hmm after
Native Americans and we're the most with
the only ethnic group that's fought in
every single war America's had we had
10,000 unknown Latin Patriots rights
into an American Revolution in the
American Revolution 10,000 and this
general Galvez he was like the George
Washington the south he had an army of
3000 Cubans Puerto Ricans Mexicans freed
slaves and Native Americans and they
kicked the British out he was like so
badass
yeah so why he's wait one second that in
history textbooks where's that why do
you suppose that is what I think it's
it's a power grab it's like if you give
if you put all this information and in
the textbooks then people have to
respect this group of people and you
have to give them credit and you can't
take away their land you can't you know
just throw them out of the country when
you feel that you can't sort of abuse
abuse them you can't if you give the if
you give them credit for the making of
America basically yeah
do you think it's conscious or people
just kind of do it without even
realizing they're doing like do you
think they they say I'm gonna leave this
out or follow those things yeah all
right and then just go to the next thing
I think it's conscious it was conscious
some point and then after a while people
just don't know anymore so it's just it
gets passed on yeah yeah how long is
this show now you should have started
three hours is it is it is it three
hours or has it been knocked down why
are you making those weird hand gestures
it's shorter it's a grower that a
contact yeah history is our Colin none
of you saw Colin Quinn so I loved it
loved it yeah he's done a great job with
keeping one subject interesting for an
hour which is not easy it's incredible
yeah yeah yeah mine's 90 minutes now
it's about 90 minutes yeah yeah without
intermission how do you figure out what
to cut from history like as you're
sitting there going like we were never
taught this and now I have to delete
half of all shoot it was it was hard man
you know I had a great director Tony
Taccone and so you know he you know I
asked but I do a lot of Q&A as well so I
you know and I was like whatever 1812
goodbye she won't believe our goodbye
Vietnam could pile over what World War
two
I was like okay I'm just gonna pick the
best moments which is American
Revolution Aztec empire Incan empires
Civil War and I camera what else he took
the Incan Empire over no no no no yeah
yeah Wow because I got to show what we
had that was lost you know I mean and
when you find out that the Incan Empire
I mean they were the biggest Empire in
the history at the time they were bigger
than the Ming Dynasty at the time bigger
than Czarist Russia bigger than the
Ottoman Empire at the time there were 33
million Incans and they had a binary
code that predated computers they had
socialism before Karl Marx that works us
successfully I mean they had a lot of
[ __ ] do you think the history teachers
that try to be like the cool teacher in
their high school looking guys like you
and Colin Quinn like [ __ ] damn they
think they're teaching everybody history
now I've been the one who's been
teaching history but you've been
teaching it wrong right the real facts
and it's not a fairy tale anymore what
happened with John week three why why
you hurting me because I was thinking
about you and I'm like so was I right
and there's clearly setting up this John
wick thing well I got going I got boned
into right but it's like now that had
monologues I had a fight sequence really
had a backstory and it got all cut out
and I didn't find out till the screening
I think they cut all of you out of just
that all of it all I I think I did
one-liners yeah I'll get your car back
to you by the end of the year so I'm
just another example of Latin history
being eliminated it's not fair he
eliminated me because my Latin hit
because I'm talking about Latin history
tell you they're gonna do it no I just
found out at the screening I'm like what
oh man I started throwing chairs you
were right I was upset you should have
been oh yeah and then they're clearly
setting this franchise up to just go on
forever but they're like he's still
gonna need a mechanic guys he knows how
to fight it not a fix cars right right
right but he'll figure it out he'll
probably they'll cut me out anyway no
he's magical right now we can face cars
all about John wick anymore good what
about when they see us exactly you leave
John wick and you go and do the most
powerful thing now are you ever done I
might in that oh my god you should see
him in it I know the dads okay
thank you so three is John Leguizamo
episode it is yeah it's my episode it is
it's the father I mean not me but the
Santana dad the Raymond Santana senior
and in Raymond Santana jr. here's what
you know you're successful with a show
like that we were talking about this
this is obviously the show that about
the Central Park five yes and what they
went to the examine 85 I never called
The Exonerated five but why I think this
show was so successful was not just
because everybody that saw it loved it
but because it completely brought that
issue back into the forefront I mean you
talk about like everybody that kind of
was kind of swept under the rug and
we're not gonna deal with it it sort of
led about light on everybody but that
was that was 89 yeah and it's not an
isolated case and it's not not in
happening now it's still happening and
it's and it's been happening and it
these are just one case that you could
use as an example to show what happens
to kids of color you know I mean when
you see that documentary crime and
punishment just came out last year I
don't thinks about the police department
in New York City no yo when I saw that
III it got my Latin up I was like what
is going on you mean there's an unspoken
quota that these cops have to have to
get and the latinum black cops were like
I can't go arresting innocent Latin and
black kids and ruining their lives just
to get a quota so they stood up these
twelve cops happening right now now
there is innocent kids lives and they
said we're not doing this anymore so the
police department started cutting their
hours firing them putting them in bad
precincts how is it frays because the
police department wouldn't phrase it
well although there's no now do they say
like well certain neighborhoods have to
have a certain amount right cuz quotas
it became illegal in the nineteen eighty
I think it was yeah so they do can't
yeah exactly so that's what's tricky how
do they ask for that well if you're not
bringing in enough arrest you're not
doing your job you're not right so it's
not like there's this number it's no no
you're direct yes we'll be yelling at
you if this doesn't happen I got to make
this happy the most that guy
you'll get taken out of your car so they
do you based on ethnicity or just that's
the areas that they're targeting or the
areas the places that it's easy to get
is Latin and black neighborhoods because
the same thing at Central Park five yeah
these parents don't have the legal
recourses to protect their kids the kids
get lost in the system and it's easy to
get away with this nonsense you know
like Central Park five these kids were
innocent the parents signed the
confessions knowing that their kids were
innocent but they thought somehow
because you're innocent that that's the
kinetic pill it'll I will sign this
we'll be able to go home we'll figure it
out yes they're innocent so it'll be
fine it'll be fine it'll work itself out
somehow God Christianity whatever when
in reality those false confessions
you're done are the most difficult thing
well the video not not even though the
written ones but the video confessions
that be forcement to do yeah are almost
impossible to undo yeah are the parents
in the videos too or knows it's just no
no the cops had the kids by themselves I
heard the parents for this yeah you keep
hearing parents the parents came after
because they got the kids first alone
then when the parents showed up there
was only one Latin there was there was
two Latin kids at the beginning and one
Latin kid wouldn't sign anything one do
the the video confessions he got out he
got away and he just went off yes not
associated other ways who did because
the kids were tired and abused and
hungry confessed that parents came
eventually and of all the parents didn't
the cops tell him that they did this
crime and the kid said we did I didn't I
go my son didn't do this but if you sign
this you know you'll you'll you'll go
home because there's a false confessions
are hard for people to wrap their heads
I guess it does happen i I never
believed false confessors a false
confession and psychologists have said
it does happen he's it does happen other
than that's like show how dim
making a murderer making a murder that's
the same thing they got a false
confession at out of the kid kid I'm not
convinced I don't know about that one
that one I'm not convinced with you I
think Avery absolutely did it Steven
Avery but that's the adult dog ya know
yeah the other thing they got a false
confess I'm up in the air the same
technique I mean it there's that yep
you know Netflix has a whole show about
false confessions now yeah oh no way
yeah they have a whole series of
different false confession cases because
I guess it just makes everything so but
it's crazy
no I mean I think it's one of those like
it's the same thing with quotas that
there is this mentality that some cases
you have to solve right like we need a
result never happened yeah it's like
it's like the pasta head there's a
headline every day right we need to get
this finished
so did Linda ferris team really screw
against I haven't seen it did she really
wrote to our beds did you see the to our
beds I did I know she's she doubled down
yes instead of Manning up and going okay
I did a terrible thing I made a mistake
but these are the this is the evidence I
had in front of me I made a mistake and
let the kids go she doubled down and
saying well just because the DNA didn't
match well the DNA matched to the guy
who committed the crime who confessed to
the crime who said he did it by himself
yes she still kind of went with the
original argument what which was okay so
he's the sixth one and the rest of all
morning off somehow that she's saying I
guess they were involved somehow but
maybe they didn't Jesse I just grasping
at straws yeah yet to double down to
protect herself yeah she lost her book
deals she was kicked out of the all her
boards yeah and then and then letterer
was kicked out by her students at
Columbia University who's the other
prosecutor with oh I mean there's like
this for me I think the scene that like
really just just just gets you is like
you see the youngest one oh right you
see the little kid 13 and this actor and
they they go back when they find them
guilty they do this great thing where
they flash back to where they were right
before they got brought in and you're
like you're looking at this little kid
and you realize like he thought he was
this was just gonna be a normal day like
any other day he's a kid he's walking
down the street and all of a sudden he's
not gonna have freedom again for a
decade
a child a chum you're gonna even wrap
your head around oh I'm getting chills
yes now and then tearing up I mean it's
so painful to is that tough for you to
be in that war like when you're an actor
on that show especially when you're
playing one of the dads did you meet the
real dad yeah I saw a lot of time with
Raymond Santana senior and the kid and I
got all the actors together with me and
we spent a little time together to bond
to try to understand how do we make this
as real as possible right because Ava
also called Linda fair sting before we
started shooting and I was in the room
when when after the fact and Linda said
I'm not I have nothing to say and Ava
said I want to know what happened from
your point of view I have all this
information I have the transcripts from
the court transcripts I have the kids I
wanted to hear your point of view she
goes I have nothing to say so she's mad
about the way they portrayed her but she
was offered the option oh like she come
back and go no that's incorrect that's
not what right right right she could've
been a part of it and shown her sorry
but obviously she was afraid right Wow
yeah I didn't know that that she'd been
given that opportunity
that's a Beth day everyone wanted to do
a really objective piece I mean that's
why this this show is so powerful
because she wanted to do the most
accurate portrayal you know I mean that
that and the other thing where the cops
you know are pulling in the one kid and
they ask the other kid you want to come
down with your friend right right they
weren't even gonna grab him no they
weren't even gonna grab this kid he's
just with his friend he's like one of
both of you come down there right and
yeah and he thought he was just going
down to support his buddy and then he
gets looped into the and he gets the
worst treatment because he was the
oldest right and what it was right to
adult prison although you know the
younger prison stuff is not I mean they
didn't portray it in the movie but it's
really it's it's worse than the adult
yeah I was surprised that they didn't go
more into the I mean I guess you only
have so many yeah yeah yeah but they
didn't show a lot of the they showed a
lot of the adult prison stuff but not so
much of the kid prison stuff and I guess
that makes it harder with the president
saying that they he still thinks that
they were doubled down I mean women
aren't sexy enough to rape or do you
know I mean remember he just said that
he said the woman the woman who said
that who accused him of sexual
it's not because look enough for him to
rape yeah I mean that's what he
basically said yeah paraphrasing yeah
yeah that's a takeaway yeah
but how do you like the deal in this but
your are you Father
yeah yes I thought so how do you when
you're sitting there right and you're
you're in this world so you can
completely understand these orchids oh
no these are their parents you're
watching this stuff happen like how long
did you stay in that space of that show
it was hard man it was very depressing I
mean I mean even in rehearsals I would
break down I mean I'll just break down I
just couldn't help it I mean it was just
like so painful so sad and and now that
I knew the dad I knew the kid you know I
was like wow it was just it was tough
did he explain to you what was the keys
like for the parents to encourage them
to sign a false confession what was in
his head when it happened like okay you
know he thought he was innocent and is
it because he's innocent he'll be
cleared somehow you know it's they
figured leave that innocent somehow is
is is a magic cure-all you know and it
doesn't and it will see the light of day
and you know just people think that
they're innocent and that's the truth is
that's enough yes no it's you know yeah
yeah I mean I you know you could see a
kid or a young person not really
realizing that the legal system doesn't
work that way there's a whole system and
there's a reason why lawyers need to be
present yeah if you're innocent that's
the big takeaways don't say anything
until your lawyer gets there right do
not say anything right a lawyer gets
there how did you really manage to make
the shift into dramatic acting like what
was the first role for you that you got
people to see you beyond the sort of
comedy and character work I've always
been doing dramatic work I mean I was in
Carlito's way back yeah I guess that's
true Benny Blanco right Benny Blanco
from the Bronx and I heard a story that
you you pissed off Alpha Chi no cuz you
kept improving on that on that set you
know I thought that was my big
opportunity it may be my only one here
so I was like I came in there like I'm
gonna tear this mother up I'm gonna rock
this [ __ ] this is gonna be my big break
I was so I was like ad-libbing
improvising
all my head all my friends like in that
scene in the in the club don't know all
my friends my ex-wife so I'm improvising
with them and for them love it
and then Pitino comes over and I'm just
yakking and making the stuff up and the
poor guy had to like listen to all this
barrage of I was making so much [ __ ] up
so you weren't intimidated by Al Pacino
no I want to show off for him yeah he
wouldn't say Dee when he called you over
he was just like you know let's just you
don't have to chew up the scenery I was
like yeah my head I'm like nah nobody's
gonna tone me down yeah this is my show
did you want it as or a lot of the
improv stuff they made into the movie
was emotion all it all made so at the
end of the day you were right I was
right cuz it made it into the movie but
who knew I mean Nick Ryder cut it I mean
look at John wick - I mean yeah I don't
we don't talk about John we do if we
don't talk about John wick anymore so
did you or did you ever do anything else
in Pacino uh yeah I did the Righteous
Kill with them that's right yeah yeah
talk about that either no continued
success when do you realize something
like that is not gonna pan out because
I'm paper you look at me hash like this
should be a writer on Gurwitch did
Inside Man I mean it was incredible the
inside the insider I'm sorry yeah
brilliant movie this script was really
really clever I believe it and it just
is it once it gets to screen you look at
it you're going home oh you know earlier
on you do you do did you think that they
said rooster and Turk enough is enough
please say the other guy's name so I
know who's oh I don't go to many
premieres but I was at that one I was at
that one too
and I was with my friend Bob who was
commenting on how much the movie that
Bob De Niro is that a no no Bob Kelly
yeah not to say yeah and Bob Kelly and I
are in the restaurant he's pissing and
he was saying how much the movie stunk
in bah-bah-bah and the director and yeah
and not afraid that De Niro Pacino of
peeing right now if the director was in
the bathroom oh you should have heard it
though he needed to hear it he did you
can't all be home runs it should be I
mean softball that was kind of fun that
was kind of fun there was some fun
elements but you have two guys together
movie make after heat was that one of
the first time they're together since
heat they weren't together in heat that
was that's why I did this movie because
heat they couldn't get them at the same
time so they they shot over the shoulder
with another actor Wow really they were
never yeah he doesn't believe he gets me
that looked like yeah he doesn't believe
me
he was like you talking yeah I don't
like when Google is exposed wait so what
but that's see when they're in the diner
together that started talking about over
the shoulder over the shoulder bro with
another standing I'd look alike standing
you know I don't be magic being revealed
I don't I thought they'd gotten the same
SUV which is set hopefully they'll be
I'm sure in the irishman there are
plenty of scenes I've seen photos right
tells in it yeah it's like that the
perfect trifecta man you know who got to
be in the Irishman who well know we'll
see again but playing that fake modest
not no no I'm just a very realistic and
I'm expecting I always expect to get cut
so I don't feel good about it so I know
you Irish yes look at the idea the only
cast Irish folk I hope so hey when you
did when you did a to Wong foo
there's no it was you it was Patrick
Swayze and Wesley of course and Wesley
Snipes you guys couldn't have had any
idea that that was one of those movies
where it ended up being a phenomenon
because it was so good but like that
easily could have gone the other way oh
yeah it could have and gone like what
the [ __ ] is this yes especially in 94 oh
my god they weren't doing that yeah
nobody was doing that I mean that was
was crazy about Patrick Swayze to take
that risk crazy to jump in being you
know pretty boy leading man
and jump in to be and try to be real
right cuz we all had to go to drag queen
school we had to go to all the clubs you
the level of commitment you had all
three of you yeah this isn't a parody
yeah
did you like it at all there's one party
that put them on and went from like I
look alright yeah I was comfortable I
wanted to do me in the trailer Q&A with
Nick Nolte nice legs on that one on me
oh my god I was you know I was so afraid
at that time that when the movie came
out that I didn't want to break the law
because I was afraid if I went to prison
I was gonna be a prison [ __ ] for the
rest of my life oh my god because they
know you as your role at the time you
know you cheat you come here come here
chichi yeah they'd want to put your
makeup on it look like the movie that
dress you had that is a motivator though
the lack of fear of jail I didn't yet
even jaywalk I was I saw mine answer the
mirrors no know what you call it crime
nothing nothing there's nothing I was
taking out yeah yeah you realize you in
a pack of gum in your pocket misses you
got to know your place and it's jail is
a place where there are there are
predators in there yeah I know like that
I want to make you look like that I go
nah yeah that's too tempting there's too
much temptation yeah but you were you
nervous that the movie wouldn't be
accepted or was that one of the ones
that while you're making it you go is
gonna work yeah we had a feeling that
something was working yeah I mean you
don't know totally the whole thing's
gonna you you can know a script is gonna
be good you don't know if the world's
gonna accept it right of course that
that we knew the script was good yes
everybody was committed to the max
nobody was phoning it in so you knew
that's another good sign and we all did
the research together and we ad libbed a
lot you know III I'm I'm the school Oh
like I like I like to I'm a writer
we write stuff so he wrote a lot of my
dialogue and Wesley was a great
improviser and Patrick jumped in too
Patrick was making up his own dialogue
and saying crazy things that Rick look
good as a woman too he did to see his
his early matron is like yeah yeah cool
girl yes definitely a good-looking
cougar yeah matronly
yeah whatever a little older than a MILF
I don't know dad no no that's a dad
daddy yeah you do your grandma's a GILF
that would be a saber-tooth tiger I
think that's right
one more Jim and Sam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
Sirius XM Adam